hello my name is hi and welcome to this
week in Android development on Tuesday
December third 2013 my American
colleagues are taking a week off giving
thanks eating turkey and watching
football in this week Android design in
action the usual team and some very
special guests speak about their
favorite design forces in android apps
and just in time to get you all ready
for Christmas Stephanie Alexander's
expertise is now available via the coax
companion Android app there has been an
interesting development with chrome and
adb call chrome adb when launched you
can see all device connected to the
machine install APK and running
processes you can easily clear the cache
data or an install specific app you can
even monitor real-time heap status of a
specific process and this is an open
source project the first episode of uxd
as Tuesday we've has mail and the very
special gas Isabelle and that's it this
week in Android development be sure to
check out this week's show I'm hoyle am
dashing food is snow in a one-horse open
sleigh